all right uh one and a half was the line
the last time i checked for super bowl
54. and peter look we're not holding you
to this you're i don't know when your
official pick what is it the chiefs
chiefs are chiefs by one and a half yeah
good i'm gonna have i'm gonna pick the
chiefs 29 and a half to 28 then
no i i'll pick the chiefs like 30 to 28.
wow i mean i have been totally on the
fence when i was flying down here i said
picking the 49ers right love the 49ers
right i love their pass rush what
changed you what changed me essentially
is thinking about all the impromptu
plays that patrick mahomes makes that's
the scary and the speed
of his weaponry and the fact that i
think damien williams is going to be a
very big factor in this game that
changed me but
i would not be remotely surprised if the
49ers won by 14 or the chiefs win by 14.
all right mvp
bless you i'll take i'll take my homes
only because as you say the quarterback
usually wins the mvp at these games the
only way i think he doesn't win the mvp
is if somebody catches three touchdown
packs and peter you made a great point
about the possibility of the 49ers
winning by 14 or the chiefs winning by
14. because
i could see
given the fact that this one feels so
closely
matched that somebody breaks right yeah
that that early on you could just like
they used to do in the 70s and the 80s
where once somebody fell behind by seven
or ten points it was like
they just couldn't they they just lost
it
i really think you could see kansas city
breaking though like i don't know i
can't see mahomes that's what i mean
russell wilson are the two guys in this
game right but here's the thing they are
unbreakable but but
texans up 24 and blow the lead yeah
titans up 10 blow the lead twice they
were up 10 nothing in 17. so that tells
me something about mahomes but the 49ers
aren't going to play that game if they
get up they're not going to let patrick
holmes get back into it i think that's
the difference
do you think do you think that the
tennis
do you think the tennessee titans said
we are going to let patrick
my point is the 49ers are better they're
better suited they're better
especially because they're going to run
if they build that leader
because they're running the ball and so
they're going to keep running the ball
and keep running the ball and keep
running the ball and just pound the
there's something about mahomes i'm not
saying there's a mythical or mystical or
anything like that quality
but
it's just like i'm in sitting in green
bay
and aaron rodgers has third and eight if
he doesn't complete it russell wilson's
getting the ball back at his own 28 yeah
with two minutes to go and two timeouts
and i turn to the person sitting next to
me in the press box i said if they if if
they punt this ball if green bay puns
the ball they're gonna lose seattle will
win the game right
that's exactly how i feel in this game
patrick mahomes late if he's got a
chance he's winning the game yeah that's
just kind of how i feel we'll see isn't
it amazing how this year has gone though
where
the ankle injury hampered him early the
knee injury knocked him out for a while
we just forgot about him we forgot about
him we forgot about the chiefs it was
all lamar jackson this lamar jackson
that and then the playoffs roll around
lamar jackson can't get it done the
chiefs do get it done and now it's like
there was never a break in that patrick
mahomes legend there was a huge break
can i tell you one quick story about
mahomes okay he dislocates the kneecap
at denver okay it's a thursday night
game they do the mri crack of dawn on
friday in kansas city and they said okay
it's not bad we put it back in place
it's okay at two o'clock that afternoon
the staff comes back in uh after the
late thursday game and they go past the
uh the hydrotherapy pool and there's
patrick mahomes
sweating
his
sweating a lot
and everybody's just saying what are you
doing here
what is his ass what are you doing here
and he had already started the process
he wanted to play the next week yeah and
he was trying to tell everybody look and
that's mahomes yeah it is he's a gamer
he loves it he does not seem fearful of
anything on the football field which he
shouldn't be because he's super talented
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports